well we've gone through half of the year
and the current anime seasons in full
throttle with all those popular sequels
and a lot of sleeper hits
in the midst of feeling the hype from
the current season's hits i think it's
also an apt time to give out
volume 4 of unappreciated anime you seem
to like those lists a lot and i'm more
than happy to give you what you want
so here we are besides there are just so
many anime per season that if i'm gonna
have to introduce all of the less
popular or underappreciated ones in my
opinion
i'd be here all day well it's about time
we get the ball rolling right
the lazy but cool teacher trope just
doesn't seem to go out of flavor does it
it's not as popular but it still comes
out every now and then in the form of
anime like our starter for this list
akashic records of bastard magic
instructor lazy and seemingly
incompetent glenn radars won't strike
anyone as teacher material much less an
instructor at the prestigious alzano
imperial magic academy
let's say he has a bit of a rocky start
with his two students
sistine and rumia however as someone
recommended and thrust into the position
by mage extraordinaire celica there's
surely more to this teacher than first
meets the eye beneath the lazy facade is
one of the coolest and most
awesome teachers these girls can ever
hope to learn from one of the last of
those magic academy light novels
adaptations akashic record still manages
to impress
the first few episodes are really
amazing for its genre
and i'd really recommend it even to
someone not too fond of the whole magic
high school harem thing
i just love the character dynamics shown
in our main trio here and while the show
does fall into the pitfall of rushed
adaptations and cut content in its
latter half i still find the show an
underappreciated gem that a lot of
people pass on because of its genre
before we continue i'd like you to turn
your attention to this video sponsor
raid shadow legends seriously this thing
legit brings back memories of the good
old childhood days when high fantasy
ruled
and now you can take the experience with
you use my links below to download rage
yourself to your mobile phone or pc
while i tell you more
rage shadow legends is an amazing game
that features a war torn land and
tension filled battles among the 16
factions that the game has to offer i'm
personally
a sucker for elves so i immediately gone
for the high elves
but i'm sure that whatever your tastes
are raid will have something for you
personally my favorite champion is ellen
she's one of the first champions you can
get but just look at her character
design isn't she a perfect waifu
material or what
tyrell who's an epic champion who's
known for his defensive abilities is
also a great champion to have in your
squad especially if you see
all of these reviews from other players
and if you start playing today you can
try a load of new updates that are now
in game among them are champion
fragments that you can use to summon
specific awesome champions with special
events running all the time
also the developers just added a new
bazaar where you can load up on high
value items with the gold bars you win
in tag arena and finally from now on the
daily login rewards have been extended
up to 270 days
with free champions available just for
logging in by simply joining the game
now and going to the link in the
description box you'll get 200k
silver and a free grinner take a look at
this amazing champion that you can get
for
absolutely no cost at all yes completely
free
for your extra rewards you can find them
in this inbox for the next 30 days
well what are you waiting for come and
join the hottest video game craze in
town now
in the nine spot is one of the many
products of the moe boom in the 2010s
sound of the sky inspired by a
trumpeter's rendition of amazing grace
ganata surami decides to join the 11
1121st platoon of the helvetian army
there she gets acquainted with her squad
who trained her to be a bugler the
series follows kanata as she learns more
about music and the world around her all
the while getting closer to her platoon
and stopping a conspiracy that threatens
to put the world at the brink of war
once again
first impressions can often be wrong and
i think that's what doomed sound of the
sky
in terms of the popularity department
honestly speaking though i wouldn't be
surprised if you passed the show off as
chaon but in the army given the context
of which it was released however
the two shows do differ in substantial
ways and i think that those who
continued on would have gotten
themselves through a dramatic tale of
hope and character growth
while it's nothing too special given how
many great anime there are out there
sound of the sky is still an anime
that's got a lot more going for it than
its popularity and first impressions may
suggest
[Music]
tokyo magnitude 8.0 finds itself at
ironically the eighth spot on the list
disaster plots are a dime a dozen but
none really strikes as close to home to
japan as disaster stories about
earthquakes with the country going
through earthquakes like nothing
people say that it would only be a
matter of time before a mega quake comes
and ravages the country
such a horrible reality is brought to
light in tokyo magnitude 8.0
tokyo magnitude 8.0 follows siblings
mirai and yuki as they find themselves
caught in the devastating quake that
leaves them in no man's land in odaiba
luckily they run into mari and with her
help the siblings look to return to
their home through a city brought to its
knees
tokyo magnitude 8.0 is probably one of
the most gripping dramas that i've ever
watched
it's a story that takes a chilling
premonition and lets us experience it
through human eyes
something that's rare to come by these
days however past the sadness brought
about by the realism of the whole thing
there's an endearing story of hope
and overcoming despair
[Music]
next seventh on the list is to be a hero
when i say that anything goes for anime
i'm mainly talking about wild premises
like this one
uncle a handsome and perverted toilet
designer
gets sucked into a toilet and gets issac
no instead he gets powers and gets
tasked to be the defender of earth
only now he's become fat and ugly
looking nowhere like a typical hero
to the point that even his own daughter
casts him out of his home now left with
nowhere to call home he joins up with
his fellow pervert yamada as they go on
their dirty conquest of saving the earth
and getting uncle back together with his
daughter
while i'd say that to be hero is
underappreciated i say so with full
knowledge of why it happened
right off the bat to be hero is not a
show for everyone a lot of people just
don't take too well to the dirty humor
the slapstick and the characters who can
admittedly be off-putting at times
still i'd think that if you're up for
some craziness and audaciousness that
only anime can provide
you can give to be hero a shot at 11
episodes each season
the whole thing is just right around the
length of a movie anyway and it
surprisingly has some really touching
moments and lessons about parental
bonding
[Music]
japanese movies tend to deal a lot with
mysticism and the parallel realms
it's something that has more or less
been codified in a lot of japanese anime
films
in the boy and the beast we have more of
that and we see the story through the
lens of
ren left with no one to call family he
runs off to the unforgiving streets of
shibuya where he stumbles into kumatetsu
kumatetsu as you can see is a resident
of the monster realm in this movie who
quickly takes an interest in the lost
boy aiming to use this boy to prove his
point and become the successor to the
lord of his world kumadetsu takes the
boy in as his apprentice
while ren begins his search for a home
that you never had perhaps there's more
tying the two together than their
partnership born out of need i really
wonder why this movie didn't make that
much of a splash
i think it's because it's not too
artistic like a shinkai film and his
setting does seem quite
ordinary nevertheless i did have some
fun watching this and i think that the
story really holds up
it's short for this type of film that
deals with student-teacher relationships
but
it does get the job done i had no
regrets watching this and i think it
deserves more credit than people give it
[Music]
ever felt like you're just floating
around in life hopping from one fleeting
job to another without finding purpose
in life then maybe
this show is the one for you golden boy
stars kintaro who rides all over japan
hopping from one job to another the
thing is
the main draw of the jobs and the
travelling for this pervy university
dropout is
the women how fitting his adventures
take him on a wild journey through
different experiences
all while coming into contact with women
of all types along the way despite often
leaving a bad first impression he always
comes out victorious having won new
experiences and learning
various lessons while leaving those same
women behind
who knows how his conquest will end you
don't hear this show discussed often but
i think it's a winner
golden boy surprised me because to be
frank it pretty much has no plot
no overarching goal no blanket plot to
keep the story going just
episodic misadventures featuring a
charming dropout and lots of comedic
edgy
yet it still drew out a lot of laughs
for me it should also be able to do the
same for you
if you have that sort of sense of humor
perhaps you're raring to find that
perverted comedy to pass the time
and i'd say golden boy could be just the
show for you
how-to shows are somewhat common enough
in anime and they do an awesome job at
giving us glimpses of the industry among
those i think one of the best is
shirobako
our number four entry we all make those
high school promises with our friends
and whatnot and for our five main
characters
theirs took the form of pursuing careers
in animation and one day producing their
own mainstream anime
years later such a dream is only
feasible for two out of five of them
while aawi and emma seem to be doing
pretty well for themselves
the other three are stuck with jobs or
attempts at jobs that seem to be going
nowhere
however with enough perseverance luck
and understanding on the workings of the
industry
surely that pipe dream of one day making
an anime is still possible for the five
of them right
shirobako takes you on a journey through
the ins and outs of the anime industry
through the struggles of aspiring youth
wanting to break in and make
it big it presents itself to be a
light-hearted show but
a lot of its content hits deep and
exposes the harsh realities of the
fabled industry that we
all as fans adore and revere in a vacuum
i'd say that shirobako is not that
underappreciated
people still look back at it fondly and
it has a decent fan base to boot
however for how great the show is and
how it stands out amongst its peers in
the genre
it definitely deserves a bit more
recognition
[Music]
now memories is a classic anime film or
rather a series of film
each dealing with different topics the
first one is a sci-fi mystery while the
second one is more of a comedy and the
third and final one is more of a bleak
social commentary of sorts i can see why
memories didn't become popular there's a
lack of an overarching plot that ties
the movies together and the title of
memories really only fits the first one
in the bunch however i'd give this movie
some merits in how it showcased some of
the best art and animation in anime
cinema in its time surprisingly the
movie still holds up in the presentation
department too
the atmosphere really hit the themes of
the short films in the anthology world
and i think the overall memories is a
hidden gem that you'd mostly watch for
the actual art and atmosphere than the
characters
i wouldn't go ahead and say this is a
film that was ahead of its time and all
of that
but i think that it's still a film left
behind by time that still deserves to be
appreciated that little bit more
the second place on the list is from the
legendary satoshi khan himself
paranoia agent musashino finds itself
terrorized by a being called
shonen bat with his signature baseball
bat he makes his move at night and beats
people down as shonen back claims more
victims
detectives begin to investigate the case
what seems to be a typical detective
story takes a huge turn into the surreal
just like the typical satoshi khan works
paranoia agent is
really scary in its own way because of
the way it plays with our perceptions
there's nothing more capable of
conjuring the scariest things behind our
own mind as they say
and this show is a testament to that
given satoshi khan's impressive resume
i'm not surprised to find paranoia asian
being overshadowed by some of his bigger
works nonetheless a number of people
find paranoia agent an amazing anime and
his relative lack of popularity just
doesn't do it justice
the show is genius and you should
definitely try it out
[Laughter]
[Applause]
foreign
topping our fourth edition of
underappreciated anime is
i want to eat your pancreas no the movie
isn't as morbid as the title suggests
in fact it's the farthest thing from a
horror or gory anime like the title does
suggest
the title actually stems from sakura
this popular and bubbly girl confides in
her classmate our protagonist haruki
shiga
about a pancreatic disease and the
limited time that she has left
despite being opposites of one another
the two classmates eventually start
bonding
causing a detached protagonist to slowly
open his heart as he slowly discovers
the true meaning of life
with a synopsis like that i wouldn't
blame you if you wanted to pass off i
want to eat your pancreas as a
predictable
character-driven anime movie that would
serve as a possible tearjerker and for
the most part of it it is it is
predictable
but i firmly believe that being cliche
and predictable isn't a weakness as long
as the execution makes up for it
and boy does it make up for it in this
movie
overall i think it's an amazing movie
that holds up to the likes of some other
tearjerker movies
it never rose to mainstream popularity
status like those titles but it more
than deserves it
how about making it happen if you're
looking for more feels and anime movies
that will surely tug your heartstrings i
want to eat your pancreas
is here for you
as we wrap things up what do you think
about those anime please leave a comment
below on which anime you think is
underappreciated i'd love to hear your
opinion on how this list turned out
as usual likes and subscribes are very
much appreciated and we'll be bringing
you some more awesome content
don't forget to check out our sponsors
game raid shadow legends
links in the description for now that's
gotta do it and i hope to see you next
time on
vinnie tube
[Music]
you